as usual nicaragua's armed forces
distributed and guarded ballots ahead of
sunday's presidential elections
but there's nothing usual about this one
most noteworthy is who is not on the
ballot not a single competitive
candidate from nicaragua's main
opposition parties
in the lead-up to the poll president
daniel ortega who's running for a fourth
consecutive term imprisoned seven
mainstream opposition candidates and
disqualified the rest accusing them of
everything from money laundering to
treason
what we are doing is trying criminals we
have plotted against the country the
security of our country by trying to
organize another uprising another coup
d'etat
the crackdown on opposition candidates
and activists ahead of the elections
forced architect maria angeles delgado
to seek refuge in neighboring costa rica
represent when the repression increased
i started receiving direct death threats
while police surrounded my house and
refused to let me leave and managed to
escape before we had corruption and
irregularities but these elections
ridiculed the world's electoral system
of democracy daniel is laughing at the
entire world by holding this type of
vote
the eu and international human rights
organizations are calling the election a
farce the biden administration has
already announced it will impose new
sanctions
but there are a handful of candidates on
the ballot besides mr and mrs ortega who
is the vice
president they are very unknown figures
in the country very little known and
they run for parties that are widely
perceived as collaborators with the
government
this video posted on social media
networks calls on nicaraguans to protest
against what is being described as a
fraud by staying at home
the catholic church has also joined the
campaign
blessed they would be if they had permit
necessary conditions for everyone to
have participated in free just
transparent and competitive presidential
elections with international observation
but president ortega is going ahead with
the election overseen only by his close
allies and in another unprecedented move
he has banned foreign correspondents
from entering the country while hundreds
of his critics have gone into hiding or
into exile here in neighboring costa
rica
there are reports that ortega loyalists
are going house to house to intimidate
voters to cast a ballot
that could make a difference in the
turnout but not in the outcome which is
already a given lucia newman al jazeera
san jose costa rica